after today's announcement let there be
no doubt about who is winning the battle
of ideas in britain
party
today it feels like the chancellor has
finally realized the problems that the
country are facing
we first called for a windfall tax on
oil and gas producers nearly five months
ago
to help struggling families and
pensioners
today he has announced that policy but
he can't dare say the words is a policy
that dare not speak its name with this
chancellor
and it was labor that first highlighted
the unfairness
of this government's buy now pay later
compulsory loan scheme
it shouldn't have taken a rocket
scientist to work out that this wouldn't
cut it and we pointed it out at the time
but that is just the mark of this
clarner chancellor announce now ditch
later
here he is once again the treasury's
one-man rebuttal unit the chancellor
himself
for months it has been clear that more
was necessary to help people bring their
bills down
so what took this government so long
every day that they have refused to act
53 million pounds more added to
britain's household bills during this
cost of living crisis
this government's dither and delay has
cost our country dearly
on this side of the house we welcome the
fact that the government is finally
acting on our calls to introduce a
windfall tax absolutely our calls and
it's good to see the snp you turning to
day two and saying that they also are in
favor of a winful tax on oil and gas
profits well done to the snp
now madam deputy speaker
it was a painful journey to get the
government to this point
first conservative ministers said
the oil gas producers are struggling
that was the education secretary i think
but then the bp chief executive said
that the energy crisis
was a cash machine for his business
so they moved to the second defense
ministers claimed that a windfall tax
would put off vital investment
but the inner industry said that
windfall tax wouldn't even change their
plans
so then they said that a winfor tax
would be unconservative
so unconservative madam deputy speaker
that margaret thatcher george osborne
and now this government are doing
exactly that
and finally the chancellor himself said
that it would be silly
silly
to offer help now given he didn't know
the full scale of the challenge
what nonsense it shouldn't take half a
million pounds of publicly funded focus
groups for the chancellor to realize
that helping families and pensioners is
exactly the right thing to do
now every day
for five months
the prime minister sent conservative mps
out to attack the windfall taxes
and yet defend an increase in taxes on
working people
he's made them vote against it not once
not twice but three times
and for months he sent his mps to defend
the litany of rule breaking in number 10
downing street set out in the sue grey
report yesterday
now there is a lesson here for
conservative mps
you can't believe a word that this prime
minister says
and as long as he is in office he's
going to continue making falls out of
each and every one of you
if they keep him there madam deputy
speaker that is the choice that they are
making
now the problem madame deputy speaker
is that you can't fake fairness
you either believe in it
or you don't yeah
labor called for a windfall tax because
it is the right thing to do yeah
the conservatives are doing it because
they needed a new headline
and we see that too
from all the other things that the
chancellor didn't address today
the non-doms keeping their tax
privileges
while they increase taxes on working
people
young working people paying more but
those who earn money buying and selling
stocks and shares
not paying a penny more
contracts handed out to conservative
friends and donors while british
businesses miss out global tech giants
making billions in profits while smaller
businesses and the energy intensive
industry struggle with higher bills and
higher taxes from the conservative party
and
11.8 billion pounds
lost in fraud because of a total lack of
respect for taxpayers money
that's why we should have had an
emergency budget today
despite the hike in national insurance
to cut business rates for high street
and small businesses to provide help for
energy intensive firms and ensure that
every pound of taxpayers money is spent
wisely absolutely
madam deputy speaker we will look
closely at the detail of today's
announcements
of course
most of them seem to have been written
by us
but so far
but so far we have seen nothing to
suggest
that this conservative government has
the ideas or the energy to tackle the
challenges that we face as a country
a labor government would have addressed
the underlying weaknesses in our economy
so we can stop this spiral of inflation
lift wages and provide greater security
for families and for our country
the truth truth is that they are running
our economy and people's living
standards into the ground
we are forecast to have the slowest
growth and the highest inflation in the
g7
this government has weakened the
foundations of our economy leaving us
exposed to shocks as we lurch from
crisis to crisis
and still they refuse to come forward
with a real plan to fix our broken
system and provide the security we need
to face the future with confidence
that means boosting our energy security
too
we need to do much more to reduce
reliance on imported oil and gas
that is why labour's energy security
plan
includes a program of home insulation to
reduce bills not just for one year but
for years to come
and to get us all the way to net zero
it's why we've urged the government to
double onshore wind capacity and to end
the delay on nuclear
while power at it
why did this tory government get rid of
our gas storage
order
it's important that we also hear the
shadow rachel reeves madame deputy
speaker while we're at it why did this
tory government get rid of our gas
storage which would have left us better
protected from wild fluctuations in
prices
when will this government provide the
strong leadership that this country
needs
now there are a number of questions for
the chancellor about his announcement
today
how many people are still waiting for
the support that they were promised in
march a third of the chancellor's own
constituents are still waiting for their
council tax discounts
is it the case
that households are still being asked to
pay the supplier of last resort costs
for those energy suppliers who have gone
bust as a result of a decade of failed
energy market regulation
can the chancellor tell the house how is
this package being funded outside of the
proceeds of a windfall tax
and if you have more than one home do
you get multiple discounts on your
energy bills
now i know that the chancellor has
adopted two of our ideas today but can i
ask why he has not adopted a third
a cut in v80 on energy bills it was once
touted as the big brexit bonus but he's
ditched that too
madame deputy speaker this is a
discredited
chaotic and rudderless conservative
government whose policies rarely last
more than a few months
we pushed for a windfall tax
they adopted it
we said the buy now pay to lay by now
pay later scheme was wrong
and now they have ditched it
this government is out of ideas out of
touch and out of time when it comes to
the big issues facing this country the
position is now clear
we lead they follow